if you had to travel through a hostile
terrain to reach an unknown Safe Haven
what would you do you'll have to escort
a kid with an insane power and you have
to be able to deliver him to a
destination that you don't know where it
is and you're not even sure if it even
exists and you're gonna have to protect
yourself and him against cannibals
flesh-eating monsters and horrific plot
twists I'm going to break down the
mistakes made what you should do and how
to beat the heaven Fortress in Heavenly
the illusion this girl is going to watch
all of her friends get brutally
slaughtered by flesh-eating man eaters
kiruko here is a deadly Bounty Hunter
and she's been assigned to escort this
kid Maru and she takes him to an unknown
location through a hostile world looking
for mysterious place called heaven and
neither of them know what it looks like
or where it is stumbling across this
abandoned town they look for supplies
and Maru starts complaining that they
have no Elites and they don't even know
where Heaven is but kiruko tells him to
stop acting like a child entering this
house they see two dried up corpses in
bed holding hands oh how cute but kiruko
then realizes that if people died in
their homes there isn't going to be any
food left to find using the last bit of
her own rations they eat and make Camp
Maru then catches her looking at an old
photo of two men she nervously then
reveals to the young man in the picture
is her old friend Robin and the other
one is a doctor who she hopes to find
while helping Maru reach his destination
killing two birds with one stone kind of
thing they sleep it off hiding away from
the horrors of this world if that will
soon find the next day they decide to
look for sediment to ask around about
their mysterious health because they are
lost but they encounter some rather
hungry thugs hungry in the worst way
possible they ask these two to hand over
all their weapons and dignity trying to
make them lose interest Mario says he's
a guy but so does kiruko sounds rather
strange and the bandits think she is
insulting their intelligence and then
this one guy tries to threaten them but
kiruko takes out this strange gun
scaring them and this one Bandit pulls
out his binoculars and thinks she's
actually holding a toy gun out of option
kiroko makes Maru try and Escape but the
band is quickly overwhelmed them okay
this is crazy because we're in a messed
up situation but if I was them we could
have avoided this whole thing by just
relying on the same logic that the
ancient Egyptians used in order to
sustain life let me explain the world is
an apocalyptic Wasteland and
flesh-eating Monsters of unknown Origins
rule the Earth and these two they're
trying to search for a mysterious place
in the middle of nowhere in a place that
they don't even know where it is but if
this is the case it makes no sense why
they were traveling so Carefree when
they should have prioritized looking for
supplies first because why would you
look for a place that you don't know
where it is you don't know which
direction to go which means you're going
to burn a whole lot more energy A lot
more calories a lot more resources
trying to get there especially since you
don't know where it is and why would you
try to fight Bandits that were just a
side quest if I was them I would have
planned better and would have looked to
gather CERN supplies first that would
have made my life a whole heck of a lot
easier it would have given me way more
return and my investment especially
since the journey could have taken a
long time we need to look for
understated things things that might not
necessarily look like they have a lot of
value but they're really worth a lot
things like bleach which will help
disinfect injuries rope and airtight
containers in order to be able to store
food that's important those would have
been the first things on my grocery list
that being said though while we are
looking for food also while it would be
ideal to go to a grocery store and just
swipe the food we are on the apocalypse
not like you have to pay for everything
all the time that being said though it
has been years since the apocalypse
habit meaning that grocery stores
probably have already been picked clean
because of this we might as well be
prepared as hell to make whatever food
we find last asking people for direction
was already risky but if we had to in
order to find locations of the sediment
would have most likely gathered around
and instead I would have looked for
areas of rivers that potentially carried
fresh water and ideally hopefully
non-radioactive fish where there is
water there is life and approaching
their mission in this regard it would
have been way smarter and would have
helped prevent them from spending
unnecessary energy looking for food and
you probably would have had to buy it or
wear steal it or kill someone for it
your two kids you're not Invincible but
Mark acts fast and bust out some really
cool moves showing everyone and kiruko
that he's combat capable but she quickly
gets tired of them wasting time and
kiruko finally fires a gun and blasts a
huge Blazer right at them melting this
pole and scaring the out of
everyone the bandits then surrender and
these two forced them to take them to
their Hideout so they can resupply and
to charge kiruko's battery there they
ask them if they know the location
called heaven or a place like what and
wouldn't you know it this one Bandit
then comes in and tells them that he
knows about a tomato Farm nearby bear
with me it's a place that houses a
peaceful community and they could maybe
try to find their Heaven There getting
their battery back kiroko inserts it
into her gun and thanks the bandits for
charging her empty weapon stunning them
because they realized they just got
played so bad they count that they have
four shots left to help them until they
reach heaven but elsewhere though deep
underground in a mysterious location
this facility houses these genetically
modified kits one kids who have never
seen the outside world and who have all
sorts of strange and weird powers run by
this old lady known as the Director she
trains these kids for an upcoming event
one that they have no idea will turn the
world into a rather horrifying place
they're getting ready for the apocalypse
completely unaware and naive as hell as
to what is really going on they go about
another regular day when this one girl
mahime tells her friend that they will
have a test today because she can sense
it because she is special and feels
things that no one else can see her
friend Tokyo thinks that she's talking
just as their robot teacher reveals
that they have a surprise test the kids
get ready to take it but Tokyo's tablet
suddenly glitches and another question
suddenly appears on their page asking
her if she wants to go outside it's
weird but she doesn't think much of it
after though she talks about her
experience with the others they've grown
tired of living inside of this unknown
location for who knows how long at this
point for unknown reasons and to begin
to wonder what's outside their walled
home mihime then reveals to them a
secret she's begun to have visions and
dreams of the outside world and two
people will come to rescue her from the
other side people that she's never met
and one of them looks like Tokyo which
freaks her out later she goes for a walk
and thinks about what mihime said but
then runs into the director of the
facility this old lady nervous she asks
her if there is an outside world and her
question shocks the director's assistant
but she confirms it and tells Tokyo that
the world outside is full of terrifying
monsters that crawl the Earth looking
for human flesh back to kiruko and Maru
she gets tired of walking and wants to
rest they then stop at this totally
innocent looking in run by this divided
face lady she gives them a super cheap
hotel rate to get them to stay hiroko
then shows her pictures of the two
people she's looking for but the lady
says she's never seen them they then
clean themselves up and have dinner and
make small talk kiruko tells the end
owner that she's escorting Maru as his
bodyguard from Tokyo in just then kiroko
spots a gun nearby and divided faced
lady reassures her that at night
horrifying creatures known as man eaters
come out around here they need to stay
indoors for their own protection excited
kiroko tells divided face lady that she
can help her kill it making her nervous
but she tells kiroko on not to worry
because it's unkillable and tells them
that everything is totally under control
that night kiruko notices that Maru
passes out quickly which he's never done
before and it's really weird but that's
when she feels herself getting really
sleepy and she falls unconscious later
she wakes up with a start and realizes
that they've been drugged hearing a
terrifying scream outside she quickly
wakes up Maru and picks up her kiru beam
and they head out to investigate they
run into the owner but she tells them to
go back inside immediately just as this
horrifying man eater lands right behind
her alright great so now this woman is
in cahoots with the flesh-eating monster
gosh we could have figured all of this
out way in advance due to the price of
the hotel This Woman's amazingly
suspicious too and the domestication of
the wild animals let me explain we don't
know what man eaters are we just know
that killing them is hard however if
there were signs that everything was
suspicious to begin with it probably is
look it's noted that when kiriko paid
for the hotel she commented how cheap it
really was and that's super unlikely in
a post-apocalyptic world is a hotel food
going to be that cheap just saying it's
not like there's a whole lot of excess
resources lying around also at dinner
the lady cooked them a full-on stew and
if we think about the current ruthless
climate of this place in times like
these they should apply the age-old
saying if something's too good to be
true probably is and in this case the
only way she could have fed these two
was by already feeding them the last
traveler the only way she would have
knowingly had knowledge of a man-eater
being in the area it was as if she ran
into one at some point and if this
happened it's unlikely that she would
have been spared unless it early on saw
the woman as some sort of easy source of
food don't quite understand the
intelligence level of these man eaters
but we can assume that upon first
meeting this woman you can tell that the
woman housed other humans regularly and
could have quickly learned that this
place was a hot spot for a free lunch
the man needed from the beginning upon
meeting this woman could have realized
that hey this is a free meal the woman
still being alive means that she likely
capitalized on this advantage of hers by
killing her guests impossible saved our
own skin and started feeding her guests
to the man eater in the area in exchange
to not be killed herself so in short
always be careful of what you eat always
be careful of older people in general
startled kiruko tries to shoot it but
the monster deflects her shot then they
notice that this creature has a defense
tail and it can move at lightning quick
speeds and it attacks them in a Flash
forcing Kuroko and Maru to run for their
lives and hide behind this little Hill
they quickly discussed the game plan to
kill this Beast Mario says he spotted
three whips on each arm but that's when
it spots them and charges at them kiruku
reacts and fires a shot blasting one arm
away Maro lures it to him and kiroko
aims for another hit but divided Face
Lady stops her and she reveals that the
monster is her son he was eaten by this
creature and now believes this man-eater
is her son and you want to know why man
eaters absorb the memories of their prey
kiruku tries to reason with her telling
her that she lost someone to a man eight
or two once these things are dangerous
and have no soul and her son is truly
dead divided Face Lady tells kiruko that
she's wrong and tries to convince them
now out of bullets for her kirubim to
give in the hotel owner tells these two
that he is perfectly safe just as
divided face lady gets her face brutally
divided in half shocking these two
kuruku reacts quickly and tells Maru
that the whip went in One Direction and
there was a pause between the first and
the second attack which means there is a
delay between attacks Maru charges at
the monster quickly dodging he swoops in
right in front of it and pushes his hand
onto his chest using his powers he
squeezes its heart the two then continue
on with their Journey Crossing this
River they soon reached this tomato
Heaven Farm Mario's unsure what heaven
is supposed to look like but he finally
ends up telling kuruko the truth of why
she got hired to escort him and tells
her his true Mission he was told that he
needs to find someone that looks like
him and inject this medicine straight
into this person when she finds him he
doesn't know what this medicine does and
he doesn't even know what this person
looks like just that they will find him
in some place called Heaven he then asks
kiroko if his Guardian mikura said
anything to him about this Mission
before she died but she says that she
was only told to take him to heaven and
gave her a weapon that she now has
before she died and that's when these
Tom folk from this tomato Town walk over
to them suspicious kiruko asks them
they're looking for a place called
Heaven the talent folk assumes she's
talking about this place since well it
is Heaven for them they take them in the
two quickly realize that no one here
looks like Maru which means that this
place is not heaven then they notice a
package nearby and Maru says it has the
same symbol as kuruko's kurubim the
mikura gave her they then asked this
local where did this box come from and
they say all their packages come from
Tokyo kiruko realizes that if they look
into this logo they might just find some
sort of connection to maru's Mission and
where this gun came from because it's
high-tech well beyond anything that is
available around here they ask this
local if there is any other place around
that could resemble Heaven the logo
tells them that some years back there
was this place called asakusa that used
to be known by everyone as heaven right
now they have a new plant they decide to
head back to Tokyo by boat to find where
this logo comes from and its connection
tomorrow because this could lead them to
the real heaven taking the boat model
Reveals His love to kiroko like a stupid
teenage boy and then he tries to plan a
big one right on on her mouthpiece but
kiroko then tells him something big and
says that while she has the body of a
woman she's actually a man
maru's kind of confused clearing up the
confusion she tells him her whole wild
backstory basically five years ago this
kid named hiruki was the brother of a
famous Kart Racer in Tokyo and they were
friends with some orphans the man in the
picture and this doctor but one day
hiruki got half eaten by a man eater and
his sister tried to save him but it was
too late he later woke up in the
hospital but realized that his brain was
transplanted into his sister's body who
donated her body to save him recovering
hiruki now in his sister's body finds
out that all her friends disappeared
from town and so did the doctor who
performed the surgery now stranded
hiruki was forced to take odd jobs and
that's how she got requested to become
maru's bodyguard and she reveals that
she is hiruki inside his sister's body
at this point Mario doesn't know what to
think but she tells Maru just to call
her kiruko he then asks her if her
orphan friend is the guy in the pic from
earlier and she confirms it by saying
his name is Robin her childhood friend
suddenly a scream is heard nearby and
one of the passengers says their ship is
being attacked by this monster in the
water back to the facility with Tokyo
the kid begins asking other students if
they know more about what's outside and
this one wheelchair kid named Taro says
that one of the air vents could lead
outside but he suddenly starts to feel
sick covering his diseased marks on his
hand Tokyo tries to help but Taro
quickly leaves she then walks past these
two kids doing something with their lips
that she's never seen before and she
tries to figure out how many cameras are
in this facility meeting up with her
close friend cuckoo she tells Tokyo that
she wants to show her something and
helps her sneak into this vent when no
one is watching and the control room
meanwhile doesn't notice them as they
watch over the children but start to
notice them displaying behaviors that
they were never taught like being
Reckless or kissing each other back in
the vents cuckoo leads Tokyo down into
this private room and shows her these
horrifying alien babies without faces
shocking Tokyo and that's when the alarm
in the room goes off cuckoo quickly
escapes back into the vent helping on a
struggling Tokyo and she leaves a
footprint Mark trying to climb up and
the two escape and this strange baby
then starts voicing the word Tokyo in
the control room guards and the
scientists alert director old lady about
the alarm but they mentioned that no
cameras have been able to locate any
Intruder they scrub through all the
footage but don't see anyone the
director then heads to their facilities
AI system called Mina and asks it for
help but also says that the alarm must
have been a glitch back to kiruko she's
fighting this monster in the water and
should reacts quickly and fires off a
round but soon realizes that she is out
of bullets barricaded within the ship
the captain says they won't reach Shore
for another 30 minutes kiruko analyzes
the mutant and says it's covering itself
with a water bubble that acts as a
lubricant and uses these hands to move
across land finding a way to destroy the
bubble might be the only way to kill it
alright look I know things are bad right
now but listen in order to survive I'm
going to rely on the innate hormonal
desires of man our feminine wiles and
the time it takes to deliver a hot pizza
to your door otherwise you get it for
free we're up against a man-eater but if
this is the case it doesn't make sense
why kiruko or Maru didn't know about
this possible Hazard before I mean like
the grew up in this world you think you
could put two and two together unless
they never took a freaking bone in their
lives man-eaters are present everywhere
which means it's not that hard to
believe that there might be some in the
water they should prepare for this
especially the professional Sailors and
also we're in a post-apocalyptic World
Regular shipping routes I'm sure often
get harassed by Pirates and even now
apparently man eaters and they're a very
real and common threats which means
these Sailors should been prepared for
such things they should have had
something anything even anti-piracy fire
hoses help by utilizing high pressure
stream of water they'll be able to push
a whole heck of a lot of things back and
some even come with semi-automatic and
remote control systems the point is is
that these veteran Sailors literally had
no excuse and they had nothing that they
could have used to defend themselves but
these Sailors are so freaking lucky
because the only thing that can kill
these man-eaters is Maru or the KIRO
beam and that is now out of ammo and
this means in order to survive we have
two options we can either try and bear
kid ourselves more or securely in this
cabin until we reach land in 30 minutes
or we can try and kill this creature
we're going to leverage our powers
against these Sailors and take advantage
of them and the time it takes to reach
land in this case I would whip out my
feminine charm as kiriko and act like
these Sailors long-lust girlfriend using
her cuteness and adorableness to make
them at least agree to run around the
ship and distract the monster if they
say no to that deal you could just
threaten them with a gun and say listen
we can kill these things and if you
don't listen we will all die either way
they will buy us time until we get
closer to land and then we could get
away scot-free they figure out how to
fight the man-eater and need two things
to kill it a dry environment and a maze
because they need to stop its quick
straight line attacks kuruko drags Maro
down to the basement of the shin she
prepares Maru to use his Maru touch they
get the monster's attention and run for
their lives down these stairs below deck
Crossing these boxes they make a final
stand at the end Mario says they can't
escape through the store but kuruku says
they don't need to as the man eater
approaches them and that's when the
bubbles start evaporating the fish
quickly starts drying up making him
realize there's weeds all around him
sucking up all the air here Maru finally
finishes the fish Off With His touch and
they've managed to save everyone
reaching land they find out from their
crewmates about the area that they
landed in this guy tells them that if
they head straight in that direction
they'll soon come across a small town
this guy then spots the bird logo on
kuruko's gun and says it's the mitsuba
company logo their company is located on
the way into town that they can follow
following the direction of the sailors
they soon spot a bird on the wall of
this building and realize that man must
have mistaken their bird logo for this
shitty drone logo and really don't find
anything worthwhile so they decide to
Camp here and head to the town of the
morning back to Shiro underground he
receives a shocking image of his best
friend mihime horrifyingly excited he
questions why she sent it Bud puts the
pig to good use anyways however the next
day though he realizes that picture has
disappeared and doesn't know who or what
did this he confronts mihime about it
and finds out that she never sent him
anything not telling her what she said
he confesses his will strange feelings
to her Primal feelings but she can't
understand what he's trying to say
outside Tokyo overhears them and runs
away bumping into wheelchair kit Tara
she finds out that he's getting more
sick whatever he has is killing him he
tries to kiss her but Tokyo doesn't
understand what he's trying to do and
runs away then she runs into Kona and
tells him that people are starting to
act weird and do things with their
bodies and mouths while Kona tells her
that he was one of the first kids raised
in this place and says that everybody
here is just experiencing normal human
emotions feeling comfortable she tells
Kona that she has a crush on this big
stud and he says he likes her as well
later that night their happiness is cut
short when everybody finds out that
taro's condition has gotten worse Tokyo
rushes to see him but the doctors tell
her that he won't get better getting
close to him he whispers to Tokyo she
should run away and tells her this place
is dangerous shocking her back to kiruku
and Maru they finally reach the small
town kuruko then goes to go get some
supplies while motto gets into trouble
again with some more random thugs
forcing the two to beat their ass and
hide inside of this hotel modern reveals
some moral useless character backstory
he talks about how he came from a closed
down orphanage years ago and got adopted
into a violent gang where he gained his
sick move gosh is it over yet and
anyways he says at some point during
this time he met mikura who took him in
and taught him how to do the Maru touch
he doesn't know why he can do it but he
knows mikura was unable to do it and she
wanted him to go to heaven to use Maru
touch there but again he doesn't know
why and he also doesn't remember which
tomikura discovered him in and leaves
everybody with a ton of questions kiruko
then mentions that While She Was Out She
overheard some people talking about a
group known as the ministry of
reconstruction according to the rumors
this group has started kidnapping people
with valuable skills and hoped to
rebuild society and fill it with key
roles one day alright look while it
might seem more like gossip the
formation of a secret government is
actually not that far off of an idea and
it actually makes sense if you think
about statistics and the resilient
mental health of humans and Kiefer
Sutherland let me explain the continuity
of government Cog it's the principle of
establishing defined procedures that
allow a government to continue its
essential operations in the case of a
catastrophic event like nuclear war and
ever since the Cold War many countries
have developed such plans to avoid or
minimize confusion and disorder due to a
power vacuum in the the aftermath of a
nuclear attack and unlike in the movie
Book of Eli or Mad Max or many other
post-apocalyptic movies that show the
absence of a government being gone
entirely such a world happening is
actually very unlikely due to the chain
of command at least in the US for
example they have a designated Survivor
ah you see what I did there but it's
actually a real thing the president if
he croaks and kicks the bucket there's
15 other people on a list that would
have to also die in order for the
government to be in a real problem but
even then one person would be a
designated Survivor and would be taken
away from the disaster event and this
also corroborates with the fact that
even in such a situation such as this a
government of some kind would still
exist however whether the government
would convince people about you know
following along with the new chain of
command that's well that's a whole other
problem and a whole other story because
having distrust with this well
apparently new government even though
it's not new it is a change and people
don't like change sometimes which means
they might have a problem and a new
faction could arise and if we take into
account of the effects that war has on
civilian mental health studies from
World War II Iraq and the Syrian war and
other similar events have actually been
shown to D decrease mental health issues
like depression anxiety and even
epilepsy because according to studies
it's because of group togetherness
basically you're feeling useful
contributing to society or a group more
and more instead and getting social with
people which means that our species and
its government are actually a lot more
resilient than most people think and it
actually would likely try to do what
kiriko heard about doing by doing
whatever they can to try and rebuild
society as this would be their number
one priority kuruku goes out to shop for
supplies and finds a map of the area
with markings of water Purity levels
telling them how drinkable the water in
each area is based on Clarity and taste
and Mario spots a 100 water Purity level
in this one point on the map and thinks
that's as good of a guess as any to
where Heaven could be because I don't
know about you but probably Heaven has
Safe Drinking Water the two then decide
to check out the place next but that's
when they hear a loud bang on the door
and find out it's one of the Shipmates
from the boat buzz cut guy he says he
tracked them down to ask if they can be
hired to be his bodyguard because he's
transporting Precious Cargo because he
is going to the immortal order just like
them because he heard there was a doctor
there who can keep you alive forever
kiruko's eyes both why at this statement
but he doesn't recognize the people in
her picture and he shows them that he's
carrying pieces of a man either because
the doctor at the immortal order can
apparently graft man eat her flesh onto
human flesh and this is how someone can
become immortal he shows them his
man-eater but realizes the flesh has
disintegrated and he begins crying not
caring at all kiruko asks him for
directions to The Immortal order and
then they decide to go stock up on fresh
water first before going there and
that's a bad idea but they don't know
that heading to the location of fresh
water they bump into this hotel owner
and they decide to drop their stuff off
in one of her rooms and travel light in
order to be able to get some water
following the map they come across this
creepy underground shelter and head down
inside there they spot the water but
also this injured man and in a broken
scared voice he tells them that a
monster just killed his friends and it's
still here suddenly this huge creature
charges at them and forces them to run
for their lives kiruko tries to take a
shot with her kirubin but misses she
fires another shot at this pillar
crashing it into this monster and makes
it pass out Maro tries to rush in to
kill it but suddenly it wakes up right
in front of them chasing him up this
pillar they catch their breath and
realize that this creature wasn't a man
eater but a bear and that's why Mars
attack didn't work on it kiruko also
clumsily drops her gun's battery down
onto the floor making them at this point
complete idiots they don't have any
weapons and now they're helpless she
tells Mario to go get it but he's scared
kiruko then proposes that if he goes to
collect the battery she'll let him cop a
feel now of course he's super motivated
and he hauls his ass over running down
to get the battery and Zips right back
up before the bear nearby turns his face
off now armed deadly and horny
apparently kuruku Tells A Love Struck
Maru the new plan Mario is going to jump
down catching kiruko in his arms and
kiriko tells Mario to run just as the
man eating bear comes out of hiding and
charges at kiruko she takes aim and
praise firing her last shot as she
blasts the Bear's head clean off and
then they celebrate for a hot second
then head back to the hotel room but
then they find out from the hotel owner
that some man came and asked about the
identities of the people that killed the
bear forcing kiruko to remember
something strange they didn't find any
drinking water at the location of the
map and instead ran into an obvious trap
this means they got played by the people
in this town and they got lured into
their hunting grounds meaning if they
didn't escape the bandits would have
likely trapped them from the tunnel
entrance the man who soldered the map
might have been in on the job too making
them now wonder why on the map is real
and what is fake realizing they need to
wait until the coast is clear they
decide to go get some shut up but monu
says hey they had a deal looking at her
like a dog with a bone kiriko
reluctantly agrees she tries to make him
feel weird about it but Mara is one
horny boy and says too bad and that's
when the hotel owner busts in and tells
him that she has a strict no nastiness
policy and drags Maru out straight to
her room there she introduces herself is
to Tori and she tells him that this
hotel is actually one giant sex house
and she has picked her prey she tries to
get him to touch her chesticles but
maro's touch suddenly does something to
her and he calls out to kiruko she busts
in as he says that it went in confusing
her and making him super embarrassed
back to the facility with the little
kids underground one of the scientists
notices a footprint in this room making
him nervous and he goes outside and
tries to match the footprint to one of
the kids shoes because he thinks there's
no way that they managed to sneak in
here elsewhere wheelchair kid Taro
finally dies making the entire School
worried especially the director she
warned her workers that this is the
second death in this school the first
one kicked the bucket herself and now
this one died due to a mysterious
disease she wonders if having these
children here is a mistake and question
how Taro got sick since their bodies
have been genetically modified to
withstand all diseases as she gets
warned by her people that it's possible
that other children could eventually get
sick as well because they don't know
what's going on what caused this in the
first place and she gets mad and orders
them to fix it before it's too late but
later she gets told that taro's body has
mysteriously disintegrated leaving
behind this strange Black Rock in its
place confusing everybody and making
them more worried about what could
happen next Tokyo then begins to feel
sick word she heads on back to get
checked but gets told that she's fine
just tired and she gets ordered to rest
in her room here she sees one of her old
classmates Spirit Asura turned into this
strange creature just as this doctor
comes in to check on her making her
vision of Ashura disappear the same guy
from earlier he notices Tokyo shoes and
thinks that she could be the one who
sneaked into the lab all right yes this
is a show but this could have been
all avoided if they just noticed this
whole thing had been set up based on
economic resource scarcity and Good Old
Common Sense let me explain why would
fresh drinking water be located where it
was as this place would have made it
super inconvenient for people to come to
and if we think about what type of water
source was there it's likely it could
have been a well or storable container
and if it was a well well then it makes
no sense why such a well would be down
there in the first place and if it was a
storable drinking container one that
wasn't reliant on being built close to
the Earth and it wouldn't have made
sense to place it down in that location
also you could have just easily been
placed above ground and more easy to
reach also the moment they entered the
staircase and saw water on the floor
that should have been their second aha
moment if there was leaked water on the
floor then that would have already
indicated to them one the fresh water in
question would have had a leak and
that's why the basement was flooded with
water too the water spilled where ever
it came from likely contaminated the
fresh water source which is a higher
probability if the Water Source was a
well and three or that the water being
here would have made the overall
location of where this water source was
located and accessible as hell either of
these three possibilities should have
rang huge alarm bells and at least
kiriko's head at the moment they saw the
water leak because she is a trained
bodyguard designed to spot suspicious
signs also kirigo didn't exactly even
consider how she came to find that map
in the first place we have to remember
that this is the apocalypse would have
posted Maru there at the entrance while
I went down to explore securing at least
a clean getaway because that's super
important and this means that kiriko
failed at every single level elsewhere
Shiro goes to meet mihime and sees her
looking up at the ceiling she points to
what she's looking at but Shiro can't
see anything making her realize that
she's the only one who can see it
floating winking things they then go to
class but that's when they realized that
Tokyo isn't there this robot tells them
that she'll be gone for a while and no
one realizes that she's been abducted
back to kiruko and Maru they apologize
to to Tori but she's chill about it and
tells her her plan is to rent out hotel
rooms in order to make more money and to
sleep with all the customers and become
the king of the hotels great later
though Maru wonders why he was able to
enter to Dory and humans in general but
they don't have time for answers as they
leave the next day to their final
destination The Immortal order reaching
their territory they quickly find out
that they are out of money to travel
knowing that tomorrow is the only one
capable of killing man eaters they set
up a man-eater killing service hoping to
attract fresh customers and well cash
they have no idea that they're being
watched this scout in the distance goes
to report to his boss Dr usami he tells
his grunt to bring them to him
immediately back to kiruko and modu's
location some other Bandits approach
them and say they might have a job for
them taking them to this rundown
Hospital kiruku tells them they have
business with the immortal order shows
them a pick for friend and her doctor
asking these people if they have seen
them but no one recognizes them making
kuruko quickly realize that these people
aren't the immortal order that now the
real immortal order is actually looking
for them but this group opposes the way
of the immortal order and they are known
as liviuman their leader introduces
herself as mizuhashi they saw their man
eater sign and want them to help him on
a mission mizuhachi shows them her fake
leg and says that years ago the
Immortals promised to fix her sickness
but instead amputated her leg she thinks
she was a part of Dr usami's horrifying
experiments a crazy doctor hell-bent on
replacing people's bodies with machines
according to rumors before the collapse
they were already trying to replace
people with machines but after the
World's End they went crazy with their
experiments and she says there's
something else going on in there when
she was in their facility she discovered
a body chopped up into pieces barely
clinging to Life by machines she
approached it but it asked her to kill
it misohashi suspects The Immortal order
is worshiping this machine human hybrid
and they must stop them before Dr
usami's barbaric ways take over the
world she asks them if they know about
man-eater transplants drafting parts of
man eaters onto human bodies because
apparently this is the sick The
Immortal order is up to and this is why
they're keeping a man either underneath
their building headquarters in order to
stop them they must kill their prized
man-eater they are keeping down there
and they'll pay kiriko and Maru to help
their Beyond convince that Dr usami is
connected to her horrifying past kiriko
accepts the job saying the doctor that
she is looking for could be there as
well maybe then she can finally get some
answers the liverman group then lay out
the game plan starting a rally the next
day at the bad guy's headquarters
they'll distract him while kiriku and
Manu sneak into their basement getting
LED in by one of lieberman's inside guys
heading down this empty basement to get
ready to work but just then kiriko sees
something on this car approaching it
they think it's a man-eater and Maru
destroys it but then they spot another
one and then they realize that this
place is crawling with these bastards
but that's what this monster sneaks up
on them and quickly knocks out Maru
before it can act and manages to
overpower kirikou holding her down more
man-eaters start to crawl all over her
and begin to eat her alive while she
screams in pure horror and they both die
I'm just kidding kiriko then gets woken
up by Maru who says that she suddenly
started her hallucinating when she laid
eyes on this man either they think it
has the power to create fake Visions in
their minds but then the creature dies
randomly just as someone approaches them
it's Dr usami impressed at their power
he says he wants their help to help him
kill someone close to him confusing
these two and putting them on edge they
follow him inside the immortal order
building to see what he wants and what's
really going on inside upon walking
inside they see patients with prosthetic
limbs being helped and it leads them
into this dark room and tells them he
needs them to do what they did to the
man-eater in the basement and Morrow
just needs to do that the human right
there opening these curtains they see
what mizuhashi reported seeing this girl
with all her limbs cut off Dr usami says
these machines are keeping her alive but
if she dies she will turn into a
man-eater revealing that man-eaters are
actually humans that are sick with the
disease and once they die they morph and
he tells them that they tried saving
this girl by amputating all of her
infected tissue but it's no use now he
can only slow down the disease from
spreading and he asks kiriko and Maru if
they can let this person now die dignity
Morrow analyzes her and says he can do
it they also confirmed that this is what
the woman here wants as they communicate
to her with this tablet they talk
directly to her and she confirms it and
Mara suggests they move her outside to
let her see the sky one last time it's
what the woman wants so they get to work
on moving her out meanwhile the protest
continues outside and mizuhashi suddenly
gets hit in the head they take her into
this building but then do something
crazy this guy lies to his people that
their leader is dead that they must take
revenge on the immortal order and find
out from their guard in the basement
that kiruko and Maru just killed the man
eater which means they can now attack
and kill everybody inside hordes of
leave a men break into the immortal
building killing this one dude enforcing
Dr usami's helpless patients nearby to
evacuate okay look this is where
everything went South and it's thanks to
these two but if I was them I would
avoided all of this literally by asking
just a few simple questions let me
explain kiriko here yet again proved to
us that she was more useless than a
whale in the desert she trusted this
group too willy-nilly and didn't even
bother to bet their story before helping
them out in the first place because if I
was here going along with such a cause
that we didn't know zip zilchnot about
not very good I would have asked them
what the exact purpose was of the
immortal people in that building and
would have questions why they let their
leader go after taking her leg if their
sole purpose was to experiment on people
by using their body parts then they
would have likely taken more of her body
or at the very least kept her locked up
and or killed her so that way she
wouldn't have told anyone or anybody or
what was going on inside of that
building and also by asking questions we
could have also had figured out why she
was able to casually see that cut of
body because just a simple examination
of the story starts to reveal some holes
and would have at least informed these
two that what they were participating in
is actually very suspicious from the
get-go meanwhile Maru gets ready to kill
this girl using his lethal touch upon
touching her he sees her life force
within her and gently and owes the sweet
lead puts her to sleep forever and sees
the patient girl thanking them for
letting her remain as a human in her
last moments and thanks Dr usami for
donating one of his eyes to her poncing
the message he begins to cry and Dr
usami meets his other patients who tell
him that the levum and Brooke have
broken in and he instructs them to head
to a settlement nearby and he'll follow
them after he buries this girl he
confesses to kirikou and Maru that he's
not a doctor he was just really good at
making Prosthetics and over time word
spread that he was helping people to
give him space to mourn and wait
downstairs there kiriko asks these
people about her friend in the picture
Robin but this one guy says that the man
in the photo looks like a doctor they
know a man named Dr inazaki he used to
work here and studied under Dr usami as
the group then leaves with the other
sediment a little while later they hear
a gunshot and they discover that Dr
usami decided to stay with his own
patient forever inspecting his now
useless corpse they discover a bun that
he was holding with the same logo as the
one on the kirubim and since they don't
know where Heaven is or where Maru is
meant to go they decided to track out
where Dr usami's logo came from so they
decide to go to Where it All Began Dr
usami's Town back in the immortal
headquarters to leave a man take it over
and say they can now make a new world
with all this high tech here not
realizing that kiruku and Maro missed
one man eater in the basement and it
just woke up the next day kirikou and
Maru are off looking for the doctor's
town trying to follow where all of his
patients went but suddenly they then
encountered an earthquake making a
building nearby them crash and they rush
over to it hoping the people from the
nearby town will come to collect it for
resources but then they discover this
weird dude already there they asked this
headband guy juicy if they can ask him
some question but he says information
isn't free they show him kiroko's pick
of Robin at the doctor and asks him if
he knows what the word of Heaven means
he then suspiciously gets back in his
car and parks at this very specific spot
he tells them he makes a living telling
stories and he might know where the
emblem means so hey they pay him any
talks and he says years ago he came
across the school building run by many
women barely captured him and kept him
as a prisoner for 10 years along with
any other band They captured forcing him
and other men they kidnapped to become
breeding pigs and he shows them his
breeding Pig tattoo number in short he
diddled women on The Daily and then he
eventually fathered his son breeding
pigs were supposed to raise the boys but
one day him and the couple that gave
Earth to his son all tried to escape
however he was the only one who managed
to escape the two women died and the sun
remained at the school Maru wants to go
rescue the Sun but kiriko doesn't trust
him she quickly figures out that his
tattoo is fake and he's just trying to
scam them they chase him away and
kirikou says that she suspected he was
hiding something behind his truck and
they spot the same envelope from earlier
on the wall they realized that the crest
on the Cairo beam is a school symbol and
then they followed the sign to the
school takahara academy reaching there
they see boxes with the same symbol and
even a bird symbol on the wall but the
whole place looks deserted kirikou finds
this letter from someone named the
director in it they figure out that this
Academy has had many branches all over
Japan and with some kind of orphanage
before the great disaster the letter
describes the outside world as a hell
making kuruko realize a huge clue she
asks Maru that the opposite of hell is
heaven meaning this Academy could be
related to maru's destination about to
head to the facility in ibaraki headband
guy shows up again and begs them to help
him on a side quest he shows them his
tattoo is real proving that this story
is true and they realize that his
mission is in the same area as the
heaven facility so they agreed to help
him heading to ibaraki the disguise Maro
up as a woman while headband guy hides
and these two women head to the facility
seeing it's empty they then run into a
crazy man eater with ice powers and they
just barely managed to escape from it
kiriko then thinks everyone here must
have moved locations it means they could
be anywhere they go back to tell
headbank guy the bad news just as they
run into one of his old breeding Pig
buddies they tell him they have his kid
and they take everyone to their little
house and everybody reunites and it's
all a hunky dory and then later that
night they start to feel super cold as
everything around them starts turning
into ice they realize that the man
either from earlier must have followed
them and everywhere around them begins
to turn into solid ice cutico rescues
everyone though and runs off to protect
headband guy's son but ends up finding
out that he is actually the man eater
hiruko he then wakes up in all of his
power stop it's insane now that this
useless side question is over kiruku and
Maru leave the next day to go back on
their main mission to find the facility
back underground the director holds an
emergency meeting and tells everyone
that Tokyo has fallen pregnant shocking
everybody they never taught the kids how
to be naughty and they suspect the
father is Kona sending Tokyo to the med
Bay the doctor's helper give birth just
as Kona elsewhere senses the children
being born later this black-haired lady
ayoshima is then announced as the new
assistant director of the facility
shocking glasses guy over here since he
was next in line and then goes to
complain to the old lady but she says
he's a part of a grand plan nervous he
complains to her says that they still
haven't figured out how this disease is
slowly killing the children pissing her
off but also forcing her to reveal
something horrifying and something that
glasses guy already suspected she wants
to use the children's brains as hosts to
put her own brain inside of them and
basically live forever in particular
Tokyo's children says they are the
freshest glasses guy warns though that
the children need to be at least 13
years old before they can do a
transplant but old lady tells him she's
running out of time because well she's
old she then tells him her backup plan
the reason why she promoted black hair
lady ayoshima as her second in command
and not him she will use her body to
host her brain and this way she will be
able to still run the facility while she
waits for Tokyo's children to grow up
and then she'll switch bodies with them
when they are ready glasses guy looks at
her like she's crazy and tells her that
this is not what he signed up for but
she doesn't care and orders him to watch
over Tokyo's children no matter what he
then goes to meet up with ayushima they
both agree that they need to execute
their plan as soon as possible because
the director's plan is evil elsewhere
bihime goes to chill out with her other
friend this girl with sunglasses named
Ohama but then she accidentally begins
hallucinating with her powers making her
end up in the med Bay there she sees
Kona also there he tells her that he's
feeling weak because he's somehow
synchronized with how Tokyo's pregnant
body is feeling she then confides in him
that when she looks into people's eyes
she can see visions of the future but
not all the Visions are real making her
sometimes see the worst and sees him as
a horrifying monster after feeling
better she sees Ohama come up and to
apologize for what she did but then she
has another Vision this time of her
being tied up and chopped up to Pieces
by these machines but then somehow she
goes through some serious character
development of the span of 10 seconds
and breaks free from her terrifying
Visions assuring Ohama that they can't
hurt anybody the next day all the kids
are gathered and are told that they will
now be put through their final test
Tokyo also shows up all healed to join
the Mina the robot running the facility
tells them that this test will be long
they must try and reach the outside of
this facility because that is the role
as hirokos and must do what they think
the correct answer is telling them that
their test will begin shortly and
suddenly the computer shuts down the
facility and locks all the adults in the
room the whole facility starts to rumble
everyone tries to escape the facility as
the Director suddenly gets off of her
chair and tries to make a run for it but
quickly gets crushed the kids around
band together and make a run for the
outside seeing a whole world that
they've never seen before realizing the
outside is safe and still thinking that
this is all a test that decide to split
into two groups mihime and Shiro are
sent back inside of the facility to
gather the rest of the kits and tell
them about the outside world meanwhile
though glasses guy checks on Tokyo's
twin children but Justin realizes that
he now can't differentiate which baby is
which he then draws a circle on one of
the babies to try and tell the
difference
ayushima then meets up with him with the
rest of the surviving scientists here
and think the babies should be headed
back to Tokyo with the facility now
destroyed and them have nothing left she
decides to execute the NOAA project a
top secret plan on how to safeguard the
children of the academy for the future
apocalypse but she doesn't reveal her
plans to them just yet back to kiruko
and Maru they spot some lights in the
distance of the ibaraki facility and
eventually reached the town nearby
switching some of their money over to
the local currency here kiruko finds out
from this building worker that he
recognizes her old friend Robin that he
actually works here as the town's doctor
excited she quickly finds him in the two
reunite she tells him her whole
confusing body swap backstory and the
name of her doctor who performed the
surgery on her he tells her that the
doctor who did it was named sakota who
is apparently the best of the best but
he lost contact with him some time back
and since then he's been working on this
town trying to grow it he then says that
she should take a totally relaxing not
suspicious bath and relax and they
should talk later kiriko then washes up
but finds that her clothes have been
swapped out with fresh ones and they
were waiting for her in her room Robin
then slithers in and tries to make small
talk and springs like a rabid spider
monkey kidoko freaks out not knowing who
she really is anymore later motto swings
by to visit kiriko but finds her
handcuffed to the bed and totally
devastated realizing who did this he
finds Robin and beats the out of
him taking him to the ground with no
emotion cutico runs out and tells him to
stop he then tells her that he likes
kiroko for who she is as a person and
accepts his fate in the friend zone
forever the two then prepare to continue
the search for the takahara academy and
maru's final objective now let's head
back inside to the surviving scientist
where they try to hand the babies back
to Tokyo but suddenly the director runs
in and she's alive and she tries to take
away Tokyo's babies but suddenly she
activates some unknown power within her
and begins morphing into this monster
encasing her body and her child right as
the Director tries to grab the baby
getting trapped in Tokyo's
transformation herself later everyone
from takahara Academy finally links back
up and Shira finally mans up and
confesses his love to mahime and he
gives her a pin from takahara Academy to
remind her of him the kids then get onto
a boat and escape the jungle as they
arrive at this unknown City in the
distance 24 years before the apocalypse
begins
man if you don't want to go through no
Apocalypse in 24 years with worms and
freaking cuticle laser beam guns and
like comment let us know what you liked
of course then like don't forget to
check out the how to be playlist down
below